don't forget to water those Mother's Day
flowers that last longer and of course
you can never forget what to watch it
begins right now 747 Vlad over to you
good to see you all hope you're doing
well on this Monday we are safe we're
healthy and while we are working from
home guys we're taking a look at some of
the stories we think you'll be talking
about including this we are honoring the
life of actor and comedian Jerry Stiller
the tradition of Festivus begins with
the airing of grievances I got a lot of
problems with you people
Kroger my son tells me your company
stinks so so good still a reamer gin the
1990s as Frank Costanza George's
high-strung father on Seinfeld when that
ended he took on another role of another
dad Arthur Spooner on the long-running
CBS sitcom the king of queens but in
fact Stiller first became famous in the
1950s as a comedy partner to his wife
and Mira he wrote in 2001 that they met
after an audition when she asked him to
steal silverware from the New York City
coffee shop their showbiz talents were
of course passed on to their children
in 2001 he spoke about his son actor Ben
Stiller success take a listen to this I
think he he got the right stem cells
let's put it this way whatever the story
is in this business you wonder about
where your kids where they're gonna go
with it you have to be lucky with
children you also have to give them some
kind of guidance and you you just have
to hope that it's going to turn out okay
Stiller tweeted overnight that his
father died of natural causes and he
will be greatly missed Jerry Stiller was
92 years old Anthony there are so many
lines I was thinking of this morning
Anthony the man's ear that's my move I'm
back baby so many good ones glad you
know he had so many lives in show
business which was one of the really
extraordinary things I remember him from
the 60s when Stiller and Meara were one
of the biggest comedy teams in the
country they actually started out as you
said in the 50s they met they met in 53
married and
19:55 and started in what was a
precursor of second city in Chicago she
was Catholic he was Jewish it was they
were hilarious Tony I think my favorite
line is serenity now but you know we've
been talking about Jerry Stiller has the
kind of volcanic father roles but I have
a little window into him as an actual
dad I once interviewed Ben Stiller his
son who told me that Jerry Stiller
invited young Ben to the set of the
Taking of Pelham one two three in the
early 1970s and it was that in fact that
made Ben want to become an actor himself
and then to further fuel the art he
actually gave Ben I think it was an
eight-track or a super 8 camera when he
was a kid oh so Ben Stiller Brailler the
actor Ben Stiller the director is really
a child to the man Jerry Stiller Gayle
that's so nice my favorite part of what
Ben Stiller said was he was a great dad
uh doesn't get any better than that he
was a great dad yeah yeah and you got to
play is defined of course in Zoolander
maury ballstein a lot of fans of that
film